last question
last question have a silly question and
a little bit more serious one the silly
one is
have you and uh damon and carlton from
lost kissed and made up yet
[Music]
all right i have never met damon uh i
did paid his partner uh
um cruz uh
um and he uh he showed up at uh the time
100
so he and i had a nice call that was
good i still don't like the ending of
lost but uh
david lindelof was supposed to come to
uh the panel
that we did at san diego comic-con
the game of thrones panel but uh
something else came up
at the last minute and he uh he couldn't
come so
we weren't able to kiss some makeup but
uh who knows we
we might have uh i it would be cool to
meet him
and for the record i loved lost i
watched lost religiously every
every episode for its entire run i was
constantly intrigued by it i thought the
uh
the premise was great and the characters
the acting was terrific
i just wish it had ended
you know like better
so yeah
and for that matter my reactions
i don't want to start another feud here
but my reaction was exactly the same
that battlestar galactica man
[Applause]
so of course i know all this has put me
in great terror about the ending of my
own series
i have two books to go and i know i
didn't know how to wrap it up good or
you people are going to come after me
with pitchforks and torches
so i'll do my best